the new switch update is here and if
you've been itching to customize your
joy con controls good news now you can
do just that step one download update
ten point oh oh you can do that by going
to the system tab in your settings then
hit system update once you're up to date
go back into your settings hit
controllers and sensors and choose
change button mapping from here you'll
be able to change the input of any joy
Khan connected to your switch you can
swap the a and B buttons change the
Ellen R bumpers and even customize
controls across left and right joy
Kahn's I'm not sure why you'd want to
turn the capture button into the X
button
but hey you totally can you can also
disable an input altogether just in case
you've been hitting that capture button
by accident you can save these settings
to a specific joy Khan or reset the
whole thing to default if things get too
messy shout out to Nintendo for giving
us all more ways to play our games I'm
gonna change my action button in Animal
Crossing to the right trigger that way
it'll feel more like Dark Souls when I
slay Tom Nook with my stone axe
speaking of which update 10.0 also adds
new profile icons from new horizons
including CJ and flick GameSpot has the
full patch notes if you need more info
[Music]
you